hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play
ominous ok this is game that's made on
the FPS ok did you guys hear that this
seems to be utter silence but I swore I
heard something ok anyway let's get into
the game this is made on the FPS creator
engine right click to pick up left-click
to throw F to turn on flashlight enter
to open available doors maintain battery
life batteries do not stack and avoid
project o at all costs I'm assuming that
project o is the diabolical monster that
I will need to avoid if I am to survive
this horrible apocalypse okay so alright
nice room with flashing lights in it
it's it just mirrors it unsettlingly
quiet in here okay no there we go ok
there's some sound I thought it was just
broken for a minute there wait a minute
something under there is that no ward
it's an award for best scream ever I
think I deserve that one ok right click
to pick up can I pick up this book here
absolutely no I cannot so C requires a
key or not
hey ok so that didn't actually require a
key so I'm just kind of wandering around
now hmm which way do I go uh uh the one
with the creepy child's toy the one was
flickering lights of doom or the one
that's totally pitch blackness that will
probably rip my eyes out let's go this
way
with the child's toy of doom there we go
flashlight worked sorry I just took some
finagling hey what the hell were you you
look like a mixture of Pyramid Head and
one of the pac-man ghosts on your face
what the hell all right then
is he just gonna pop out randomly at me
what's this can I move this okay I know
that in some of these FPS crater games I
can move stuff but apparently not that
alrighty then I also can run very
slightly if I just move
my limbs just a little bit faster I
would be able to go places hi you look
like you're made out of play-doh you're
probably this isn't horrifying and gonna
rip my eyes out but you look kind of
kind of weird actually it's kind of
unsettling looks like a big day
stop that okay you're gonna stop that
now it looks like a big teddy bear then
ate too much little overstuffed gonna do
it again you're gonna do it at every
corner that I walk around okay good
thank you very much okay so it's dark
apparently my flashlight is on but it
sure does oh wait what what are you
kidding me
my flashlight is on right now it made it
darker for some reason on/off Wow okay
I'm not doing that anymore
maybe it's just like local I oh this is
very very slight I I think there might
be a bug with the flashlight mechanics
oh there we go
kinda I guess maybe I can see barely it
is really dark okay that one actually is
locked and I can't get through there but
I'm about to run out of battery anyway
so I don't know what I have to deal with
oh that's what that is that is the okay
no it's not one of those videos it's um
that was he Locker that was blocking my
path before so I don't know why I was
supposed to go down there any way other
than to find the luck
oh my battery ran out okay I wanted
quite sure what the hell happened there
yeah don't be nibbling on my giblets
there mr. monster man project oh these
flickering lights are gonna get to me I
gotta say for an SPS creator game this
the look of the game is actually pretty
good it's got a lot of atmosphere I just
would love some more ambiance to it
because there's no ambient sound there's
nothing even the jump-scare sound isn't
that intense even that look at that that
actually looks pretty good
surprisingly most of these FPS creator
engines look like
oh hi did you just decide to lay down on
the table there for a little bit is this
your secret memory location of doom
probably probably
so project Oh is some horrific medical
experiment I don't I don't have any new
Lukey Wow all right then don't do that
to me
ah you're way too close for comfort
there I could smell your stanky ass
breath on my face please no hey this
bicycle is broken all right then press
ENTER to install flash memory yay I got
a battery I don't know what they mean by
don't stack but the battery does not
last long
turn on there we go okay it's on so I'm
gonna go down this dark corridor while I
can see anything at all you know it's
kind of a mixture between unsettling and
unpleasant with the total silence is
that water
oh yeah that's water why is there water
here
like I said FPS grader I didn't even
know there was water in the engine and
this actually looks good cuz it's got
reflections and warpage miss I'm
surprised I'm impress no I don't always
say that graphics make a good horse good
table bad you're weird and freaky and
bulbous and odd shaped and you stink
okay this is another block press enter
to install flies oh I got a new battery
okay thank you okay alright then I can't
always see where they are but alright
then apparently I get them and that's
all that matters so it seems like each
new battery I get my flashlight gets a
little brighter was this this open a
bowl no apparently not okay this is
weird
hello hello hosannah new that's a new
flashlight battery I'll save that one
for when uh this one good
stop that I don't like it
you're ugly your mother's a hamster and
your father smelt of elderberries
healthy berries you know back when I
used to be a bartender there was this
elderberry liqueur that uh that was used
in a couple cocktails that I made it was
very good like I've never even tasted
elderberry before that
Oh also I used to be a bartender doing
it and I ever tell anyone that I don't
know I don't think I've ever mentioned
that yeah one thing I liked about being
a bartender is that um if you can make
people laugh you get better tips but
you'll never get better tips than the
girl beside you with the giant boobs and
that's always that always made me upset
cuz I can make people laugh but goddamn
I sure wish I had boobs you can quote me
on that
markiplier says ran randomly then I wish
I had boobs sure would make life a lot
easier
okay maybe I could show my boobs to this
monster and give him to go away oh okay
he's gonna pop up here in the Edney na
oh no touch I know he was still got me
it's not that it's like scary it's just
startling and usually I say that's a bad
thing but it's kind of affecting me I
want to know what these have these
speakerphones or four yeah I'm really
gonna say I've never seen as much work
put into the level he doesn't oh my god
okay he does it in every room I don't
know why I'm still surprised by it okay
I just flipped a switch
I only think he's even actually gonna
kill me okay I'm just gonna you know I'm
gonna replace battery every time I get
it because I don't know what the hell
I'm doing anyway so might as well get it
hi that was a little farther away thank
you very much I'm not gonna go that way
now unless you're gonna pop up over here
too mister yep hi do you have any
animations at all
oh whoops don't want to go that way I
need to go a lake that's probably
returned because I needed to get a key
for that door that was in the beginning
of the areas so if I can find the key
well this doesn't help at all
Wow what the hell what am I gonna do
about this this is this is not good I
haven't found anything I'm just gonna
drop back to where I was before and be
none the wiser I'm also running I wish
this flashlight did something ding dong
damn it Oh
duh I flipped a switch that probably
opened the door okay I'm a [ __ ] I'm a
stupid ugly face who's me
okay let's just see what's around the
corner by the way sorry I'm still sick
but uh I'm a little better than I was
before so my throat's not bothering me
as much I'm just still a little loopy
have you good tell Dad barb I want boob
on him in in hittin him huh
nevermind that's getting a little too
weird if you keep it normal for the
audience think of the children
ah all right anyway so hopefully there
will be some new jump scares probably
not I'm about to run out of flashlights
but oh I wonder if it'll make it
brighter in this area probably probably
yup just a little bit brighter don't
know why oh and in case you guys didn't
know whenever I put out a video I always
try to make sure that the brightness
gets turned up a little bit when I edit
it so that you guys can see a little
better than I do
the locked oh no wait not that way
I need to go to left here press enter to
install new flashlight was there one on
the table here where was it did I get it
there we go okay this will help me yeah
for sure
ah apologize I'm sorry I still got stuff
stuck in my throat I'm fighting back to
tickle the whole time talking usually
else but when I'm sitting here alone in
my apartment in the nightmare of my own
mind sometimes things get to me like a
cough okay so I got this and then I get
out I think I used up all the jump
scares I don't think it's adaptive in
any way I wish that it was a little
better but it just isn't
is this open now hello or am i going
completely the wrong way ah I thought
for sure I am so wrong where am I
supposed to go then I must open the door
somewhere else well piss and vinegar I
guess you're just gonna be entertained
by the sound of my voice for just a
little bit longer and by golly I wish
this actual sprint made me go just a
little bit faster I feel like I'm
holding down shift for no personal
reason okay whatever I'm not gonna
complain I'm gonna turn off my
flashlight or not you got you got to not
be pressing anything else when you press
f that's why that is what it is so if I
go this way and then I go straight down
to the end what was at the end here what
was done that was down to the thing
where did this go was there something
else down there that I needed to find I
don't know but all I know is that I
would love to find better flashlight
battery tech there must have been
something else down there but I've just
overlooked okay it's a little bit
brighter when I turn off my flashlight
don't know why oh well it's dark I can't
see whoa oh I'm already at the bottom
but I didn't even know alright then oh I
know what that probably opened that
probably open that vault looking door hi
yep that's the door you know when you
look down the hallway and suddenly get a
chill down your spine
yeah that happened this is the kind of
thing that I would normally nope the
hell out of here but oh
okay okay bye
okay okay okay can I have that is that a
key oh you can statue doesn't make it
any better
can I have that what can I have that
could I have that please how do I get
that from you
hello baby how you doing it oh good
thank you
hmm wait a minute let's go there it is
okay I'm okay so is this the key to that
door over there Baba bleah okay let's
just go and try it's not that far turn
on my flashlight climb up the stair use
and then get the hell out of here and go
home I don't know why that was so creepy
it just was like some things in some
situations dead silence can be very
unsettling because I mean in what
situation are things totally quiet
you'll jump out of a gun good that's
what I thought
you don't wanna mess with MA no no yes
too strong for you that and you haven't
done anything a lot more creeped out by
that statue than this actual monster I
mean you did get a good few good jump
scares when he was like pitch black that
was a good one but not now
all right what's gonna happen what's
gonna happen I bet they're still gonna
be wrong somehow somehow god I can't see
a bloody thing kind of anything I don't
I can't even see where it is there it is
right there we go okay god that is so
freaking hard to see there we go I'm
outside it's beautiful but not really
but Oh Oh suddenly the sky got brighter
boy
weird okay I don't get it I don't get it
but then again who cares okay don't go
towards the moon yay
all right those it okay cool beans
well that was a game um it was pretty
good I mean it has a lot of potential
there was a lot of work done in on the
level design and that's really good when
you have attention to detail like that
it's just that the jump scare was so
lackluster I mean it still got me
occasionally just cuz you know you throw
it a hundred times you get him a few
times but I mean you could do a lot more
work on you know making the jump scare
more selectively making the enemy
actually animated he was just a static
figure there was no danger I don't see
how I could have possibly died in that
game also like uh use it to your
advantage like those unsettling moments
like that long hallway down to that
statue at the end those very unsettling
and that was perfect and it could I
don't think that could have been done
better but um need some ambience for the
music and stuff like that got something
Mei but that's okay so anyway thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation more videos that I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye
haha
okay road when she park is about to be
HJ
Oh God
who
poke
of your throat